[Music]
so there's this kid on YouTube who makes
each content you might have heard of
them his name is boa hello Bulow Oh
Bueller you left I don't know hello yeah
and that's the one call you Bo yeah
arrow says you're the bestest Bob this
true since creating his channel in 2016
Jason and Bobo Dodie has amassed over
800,000 subscribers and one of the most
fanatical followings in eSports
uploading montages of plays that make
diamonds look like coppers
oh my god polo back in the day a lot of
people thought I cheated so I was like
you know maybe maybe this will help sway
them like maybe like if they see my
gameplay like they understand is like oh
maybe he's not cheating bolo is one of
the most mechanically gifted seed
players in the world when I first saw
bolo brake on of the scene it was this
almost inhuman accuracy and they coined
the term like bolo
flick-flick and bolo lien and stuff like
that because of just the way he played
and you know we've seen crazy players
step forward but then he comes forward
and he does something that a lot of
people haven't whether he's pulling off
his signature one task executing some
incomprehensible wallbang hmm oh my god
I [ __ ] achieve achieve got [ __ ] or
just absolutely [ __ ] on pro players
Boal has gone from a pub star who
everyone accused of hacking to the most
highly touted prodigy the game has ever
seen bolo is one of the highest raw
mechanical players that I've ever seen
and now he's finally 18 old enough to
play in pro league and to be the
faithful TSM's newest seed roster
you know polo has been a very prized
commodity and a sought-after prospect
for a very very long time ever since
this game has come out and he's been a
household name throughout siege it's
official this youtuber has hit the big
time and everyone is asking the same
question when does bolo play
[Music]
hey guys if you want to follow more of
Bobo's journey and cease eSports make
sure to tune in to be soft six major
Raleigh 2019 you can find a link in
description for details
now Bo's Road to see to stardom began in
2015 when he first picked up the game's
open beta CS go looking pretty boring
I was playing csgo for three or so years
sausage come in I tried the beta just
the format of the game like the MOBA
style of like operators and everything
like how there's counters here you know
every single one I don't know I just
kind of liked it by June of the
following year the 15 year old phenom
decided to upload some of his gameplay
footage onto YouTube and from the get-go
it was clear that this kid was an animal
[Music]
I just had some friends are like hey you
shouldn't you know upload on youtube
make make some montages this and that I
was like you know sure why not but there
was one problem
Bowa was actually too good yeah okay
yeah okay that is so he just randomly
shot through the garage dude literally
he shot at one spot he completely
flicked to the other side of the garage
and shot and killed me
head shot me right in the head and blow
is not this this kid's not legit now
boba wasn't a cheater
he was just an absurdly talented 16 year
old with inhuman aim otherworldly map
awareness and a hilariously
unpronounceable name hey boy I think
he's stupid and it's annoying that's all
eventually he decided to lean into it
it's placing clips of his accusers into
his highlight reels no drones sprint on
in with the call out of there in there
in church and so he just sprints through
nope I don't even I don't even care if
he's just gonna go use this in a meme
video
report by little every single [ __ ]
time I ever play here back in the day it
was like you know cool you know like
they think I'm cheating like you know
listen I'm just dumpster eating them and
they're just there's Matt over it he
came to a point where like I try to get
my name out there in like a positive
environment and everything like I try to
like grow my name
especially my brand but everybody thinks
I'm a cheater and I can't escape that
once 20:18 rolled around Bobo became the
scourge of even North America's best
pros players who despite already being
in Pro League we're constantly being
asked whether they thought boa was the
be-all and end-all of siege well sir I
just think at the end of the day we all
need to [ __ ] come together as one as
one unit and take down [ __ ] abuelo part
of the hatred stemming from the fact
that they all thought he was cheating so
dying to Bobo was never an embarrassment
once they realized he wasn't though well
oh [ __ ] it didn't take long for the
community to wonder if Lola was the most
naturally gifted player siege had ever
seen bolo is one of the highest raw
mechanical players that I've ever seen
mi in Milan in siege that is right he
has incredible mechanical control over
his movements and that makes a great
player the problem was that no one could
actually figure out if that was true see
boa wasn't a team so he couldn't play
and pro league no matter how good he was
but the speculation continued bolos
actually gone that [ __ ] he might be
disgusting and probably he might be he's
placed on his rank playstyle Harvison
right but if you just take his aim and
just put that on an actual good pro
league player i actually don't think
bolos that he's brain dead I don't think
so I don't think he's smart but I don't
think that in April 20 18 he joined
disrupt gaming and when CCS season 3 one
of sieges most notable community league
but he still has a bolo pressed right up
against him on the cash wall the board
trying to take the angle but it'll be
bolo to clean it up
DG disrupt gaming are your North
American CCS season 3 champions as 2018
drew to a close Bobo had become one of
the biggest content creators in siege
and in October he decided to leave
disrupt to focus on expanding his
explosive brand I am no longer a part of
disrupt I have left I am done
no more destruct Olo PG no follow
disrupt no bolo bolo that is the name
and that is it and by this point bolo
had basically become a celebrity
pickleball Oh summer
hello hello Bulow Oh Feuer I don't know
lo yeah that's the one call you Bo yeah
yeah I heard there was some troubles
trouble with the pronunciation
everyone says you're the best Bob that's
true okay oh my god a [ __ ] bolo
eventually rumor started to spread that
as soon as he hit 18 wellwe would get
snatched up by some team with a probe
league spot
some people even suspected that he'd
already signed a contract which wasn't
that surprising considering that Bobo's
fanbase was a little obsessive
honestly chats less toxic when I'm
playing cheaters than when I play
against polo like honestly like the
people that come here just like me in
total aids like disgusting from the
sewers to be honest like my community is
everything to me like they do have
tendencies to kind of again get rowdy
and everything but like I think that
that same amount of people there's also
people that are supporting me till the
till the end essentially and it's just
like it's unbelievable
by this point pros had gotten sick and
tired of being asked what they thought
of him one of my thoughts on below I
mean he's cool I don't know why people
ask that so much what are the thoughts
on below like finally on June 4th bol
announced that he'd be playing season 10
of pro league with the former accelerate
deeming roster and the community went
bananas well chat we all know what's
gonna have it in chat today right thing
google what's your thoughts about polo
joined pretty well have you seen about
forward german tingle bordeaux think of
bottle like realistically like it's been
like a dream since I've been playing C's
and I would tell people like down the
road like you know a content creation is
my priority you know this and that just
to kind of like hush a people like so
they could stop you know bugging me
about it but like deep down like deep
deep down I've always wanted to like
play competitively and you know pro and
then on June 16th
TSM picked up the roster bo didn't get
the jump on the server quite yet though
see his 18th birthday wasn't until two
days after tsm's first game so he had to
sit and watch from the sidelines as his
teammates racked up an L without him by
a logic it said of arsenal Holt trying
to hold on to this site do
best butt will fail and there you go 92
dream team beating TSM 7 to 4 on
clubhouse he played his first match two
days later the day he turned 18 and help
this team secure a tie against Space
Station gaming and their roster will
have a name on it at the very top that
you might know and be quite familiar
with bolo making his pro league debut
and there's gonna be a very large
spotlight on him he has an immense
amount of fans foreign and the bullet
for the stairs over what I like the free
fire on the thinking Nate and it catches
his head and Bolin will find his very
first pro league kill the lion will push
on in Merc gets one rampy will twist
looks for a second but won't grab it
Bolin will shut him down and TSM will
continue to go we're barreling towards a
draw here at Space Station we'll find
themselves and another opportunity drop
big points on the board that'll be it
it's a perfect trade between both Chawla
and polo and of course leave it to polo
to be the person to get the very final
kill after his debut
even though TSM haven't had the greatest
start to their season both very presence
has increased any Pro League viewership
substantially since bolo came to pro
league the views for his games have just
been absolute bananas they have smashed
records for most views within like 24
hours most view games and he you know
his fans and chatter about him dominate
the twitch chat they dominate the
subreddit they dominate interest on
youtubes it's good to see cuz like I've
always been a fan of Pro League I've
always been a fan of the competitive
seve scene and to like not or don't
quote single-handedly but like have a
pretty big impact on like increasing the
numbers and getting it out there to like
everybody else is just fantastic
Rainbow six Pro League deserves every
little like support that they can get
and it's essentially the future of
rainbow every week legions of fans tune
in to TSM's matches to see if this is
the week when boa will finally dominate
but she moves to the left while she's in
a lot of trouble and there's bolo
missing his shots but don't clean up and
Jason Doty will save the
really good performance from Ebola with
14 kills Merck as well feature the
community has even gone so far as to
make a website called when des voeux
play calm ladies and gentlemen in case
you were wondering bolo plays match
number one today there's no question
that bolo could become the simple or
sumail of siege and it's safe to say
that TSM knew that when they signed him
see I said um this is not their first
rodeo
like they did that very intentionally
they know if they're gonna enter Rainbow
six they need a strong content creator
to do it they wouldn't have entered it
unless they didn't know that
that said juggling content creation with
professional play is a tall order and it
remains to be seen whether bol can
balance those it's really hard to
balance content creation and playing
professionally right because for most
people playing professionally is always
going to take priority content creation
is what will take like my name's like
the next level and everything like that
is my like my main future but my
priority does lie within Pro League
because again it's something I've wanted
to do for so long it's probably not the
best decision you know prioritizing in
pro league over content creation but
that's just something I want to do like
that's like my aspiration and dreams
essentially the last time a youtube
prodigy competed in pro league it didn't
go so well and last I met a poorly
player like that it was serenity 17 and
he literally got so depressed from it
that he stopped playing him like Jason's
I call it one of my favorite people in
siege I would hate that fully changed
him because of that I feel bad for bolo
and how passionate his fanbase is
because they set expectations that I
think can often be unreasonable the
pressure is definitely definitely there
and I don't think it'll ever disappear
there's a reason it's rare to see
someone go from content creator to
professional player aside from the
hectic schedule there is a huge gap
between high level matchmaking and pro
leagues but bolo might be good enough to
cross it it's definitely a change of
change of pace for sure still is still
adjusting we're slowly getting there but
I think give it give it a little bit in
TSM Ola
definitely be a force as well oh he's a
nice shot on to laxing there's still one
HP on skies so did you have the ability
but just how low and that's guys down
below 5/2 and he's gonna be a little 1b
- now the anger comes fly across but no
it's gonna be bolo picks up an ace
but murk is gonna have to be that one
player to not mine bolo will get the
final kill there from workshop its gg
it's going to the Rolly major for TSM
aggressive tank and bola with a nice
flick on the bullet can he find the
second and he will follow show and
everybody I was done below playing close
to the door as well as he goes for the
pro angle de Bourgh his way around yes
watch it but it's pouch oh man
to main stage and North America has
their second representative way low wall
Oh
buh-buh-buh that's bolo I've been I've
been around for quite a bit and you're
still calling me some weird weird
variation of my name its bolo